axolotls are a conservation paradox for  decades this strange salamander has been  used in labs all over the world to study  everything from development and cancer  to limb and organ regeneration but in  the wild this popular research animal  and pet is headed towards extinction  the natural habitat of axolotls is the  murky canals of Mexico City but  researchers have discovered that their  population has dropped from up to 6,000  per square kilometre 20 years ago to  just 35 per square kilometer Mexican  scientists are studying these remaining  wild axolotls and trying to combat the  various threats they face like pollution  loss of habitat and the introduction of  non-native predators like carp and  tilapia most captive axolotls are  extremely inbred making them vulnerable  to disease and genetic abnormalities so  saving the wild salamanders could be  vital for a search as well as the future  of this fascinating species